welcome to this video against inmortal
in mortal okay Gustavo magia okay honey
i really don't there's so many total
players are all you never have heard her
so this guy is about my rating well
unfortunately my rating has dropped i
had a really bad run last couple of
games let's see what is doing against
the Quincy to Bishop g5 line that I tend
to play
just be five is kind of normal what okay
poor interesting there are moves out
there you really need a moment to grasp
queen d 5 ok I don't want to trade the
queen this is really habit meek so let's
just go to see to
yeah obviously tries to go for some some
sort of quick counter play or anything
with Bishop before I don't know maybe
with Bishop b4 Queen a5 this early this
early pinning business I mean I mean
otherwise I really have a hard time to
understand what he's doing here just
moving is Queen night to two times and
weakening this position all the way it's
a bit strange maybe you can win try to
win a pawn with g4 night XD forward by
Queen txt form but I have a hard time to
believe in that what are you drunk or
anything I'm sorry to be so Frankie what
this looks like totally ridiculous what
he's doing I mean it looks really weird
may I could have taken on age seven but
be too was hanging so there are some
some things like wake opening rules like
developing piecing pieces and making
sure your King gets out of the middle
those kind of things and they don't seem
to count ok and II form Bishop c5 maybe
with the night be three okay I'm trying
to open up the position protein
some with a shake-and-go Bishop c4
so just Bishop c4 we are making sure
that you cannot easily castle now we
just haven't even Castle short simply we
should night a sticks okay okay yeah i
think i will castle short this is the
safer position for the king rookie one
coming check ok and rook 81 oh wait wait
wait and I will take you first I will
take you for this is much stronger get
rid of the defending night and only now
continue because the bishop is not so
useful in the attack the bishop was
useful to prevent him from castling but
now I don't need that anymore and I just
can put luke a 2d one
yeah okay you won this is a winning
attack no way that like can save this at
least if I if I don't do anything
totally stupid now okay look these seven
looks looks normal right if five looks
good you can also just take
hmm
taking on the seven I'm not sure how
convincing that is but yeah really going
to do that anyway it looks kind of
normal check breaking through let's see
rookie 695 so that's not going to work
and here okay I cannot give a check I've
night queen 85 now can check can't start
with this move well King bee 795 is
going to win and King d7k d7 95 my take
I just give the chicken can I don't
believe that you can survive this kind
of thing going here maybe you can maybe
can go to f8 and it's not that bad okay
okay that's maybe maybe an argument a
sign warning I see that now I didn't
play that didn't play this in the best
possible way definitely not check it's
not it's still quite good but it wasn't
as convincing as it should have been
check let go here's got this check and
clean h6 which is really really annoying
yeah that's that's annoying i should
have really totally punished him for
this for this for this play but i didn't
manage i didn't manage at all check
night this is this is really a shame
check check check check check black
forfeits on time yeah that's the right
result at the end but not very deserved
anyway because or what I mean this is
just check mate and I didn't do it this
is totally embarrassing for me this is
just I mean why didn't I find a
checkmate IAM in this position what is
it that wins probably almost any move
but not what i did queen d 1 is winning
young yeah but probably this is also
winning would be I'd would be really
astonishing if it wasn't check brooke d
1 wins check which is what i played and
now i would hear ok and this this seems
to win and I cause his hangs with check
hmm this seems to win check and then
this is winning the IRA it's not totally
trivial to find those kind of things but
I mean I was really a bit harsh on his
opening play right this is just this is
just ridiculously bad I'm sorry it can
be an IM for whatever reason but this is
just bad you cannot play like that even
if the computer is giving is equal this
is just rubbish you're totally weakening
your position you don't develop anything
this is just nonsense it's just bad so
let's see ya here the computer even
agrees
and down on clone castle there may be
long castles but this is just terrible
Plus about plus 2 now the comp will
probably go up over a while maybe I
should have taken first and then check
this is this is really it really should
lose quickly and i didn't manage that
this is a stronger move ham this is
stronger because it has this this
immediate threat if he does this have
Rick e7 okay yeah this is much stronger
in fact Queen d2 now one or two precise
moves help even this is now check now
I'm now winning with 95 coming this is
all like + 3 + 4 according to the comb
so it's really a direct win what I'm a
bit surprised about that in this in this
kind of position the computer is giving
it as equal which is hard to believe
that White's big advantage and
development shouldn't count for
something maybe it takes for a moment to
2m to to to to get it and now it's
getting to a slight advantage for white
with you form which is what I played and
not here yeah maybe the calm takes a
while to to get to figure that out but
here yeah it wants to do this which I
understand this is certainly better that
you flick this in and here well I mean
this should be really good compensation
with maybe it's not totally overwhelming
possible you can can argue about this
kind of line maybe we're getting a pawn
back it still looks strange for black
but maybe it's not totally totally weird
well this is really bad I mean if you
cannot get the King out of the middle
your most probably not going to survive
this and then check the way it went I
applaud Thompson winning check
chevening opportunities check and here
is sort of i mean i still have good
compensation but it's not a win anymore
between age five is still strong check
jung da-jung yeah i'm just struggling
and I should should lose your time and
on position probably but I ask this one
which is pretty strong i would say can
resign after that we went here okay it's
useless to analyze yeah I even have some
some decent play against the king
computer gives is equal with a perpetual
basically yeah okay well I should have
really punished this opening much harder
thanks for watching